Mike Freeman NFL reporter for bleacher
report and who usually give his you know
top ten things there's all these moments
there where he's looking at certain
things in the offseason and this one
captured my attention today when I saw
that you know the Cowboys with Ezekiel
Elliott it started his floating out
there and you sort of had the
juxtaposition of the Cowboys cutting
lucky Whitehead who didn't do anything
wrong apparently but he got cut
meanwhile Ezekiel Elliott is he going to
be suspended and I wanted to have Mike
on to talk about that Mike good morning
thanks for joining us where do we stand
with this investigation with the ZQ
Elliott and Jerry Jones's role in this
well first of all they have to thank you
for doing more work for me you were on
on your near shows recently talking
about the influence of Jerry on this
investigation how other owners and other
people on the league recording illegals
to complain about it yes I saw that and
said oh that's thanks dad okay so I'm
here for you Mike I appreciate I know
you are you're a really good man I know
that and calling around you know you
were dead-on and I mean in fairness you
made the point about how owners and
other people from the league always
complain they always call Goodell to
complain oh it's called illegals
complain about something or say another
team cheated why aren't you looking at
them that's what happened in to flake
eight basically that's what's happening
in this case and I think we're we are is
the league is taking a really long time
to look at this and people around the
cowboys on the team people around the
Elliott are taking it that to mean that
he's going to face some type of
suspension and I don't think what
happened in the bar will help much they
there's a feeling that maybe the cowboys
and Elliott need a lesson because you
know some as much as I love Jerry and
love that organization and it's you know
that quarterback dak Prescott is so good
and measured as such a great leader I
mean you look at some of the arrests
they've had and some of the things off
the field it's it's there
a little bit of an issue there and I
know the league is sort of looking at
that very carefully so all of these
things are at play here Dan it's going
to be interesting to see how it all
comes out but it's going to be basically
people around that team think that
they're going to face they'll is going
to face some type of specific because
it'd be investigates council wall but if
you also look at what happened with
lucky Whitehead they said this was an
accumulation of things well we're kind
of bordering on an accumulation of
things with Ezekiel Elliott so you can
cut one guy and are the Cowboys would
they have the wherewithal to discipline
Ezekiel Elliott or are they waiting for
the NFL to do the dirty work that topic
plus are we talking about things that
happen prior to getting into the NFL
which I'm still amazed that you know
this happened to Pryor when he was
coming in from Ohio State got
disciplined so it I know it's
wide-ranging topics there but the pick
and choose where you want to go with it
well you know how this works it's if
you're really good
there's a different standard yes and if
you're not really good if you're just an
okay player and Ezekiel Elliott is
really good so what happened to lucky I
mean it it's crazy that whole how that
all unfolded but that would never happen
to a really good player somehow the
kaaba's Cowboys will say well he was a
mistake what we're going to invite them
back it's just a different level for
really good players I mean you know that
so that's that's one part of it but I
think there's with Elliott you hit on
sort of the main point with him there's
just it's not like he's done just ease
these lists is this litany of horrible
things you may have done a really
serious terrible Act we don't know but
you know the bar fight it's just not
smart like just you know the NFL's
watching you so you can stay home and
watch a little bit of Netflix
you know Star Trek on Netflix then you
can watch that each space 9 is really
good series Captain Kirk is a really
good captain get into that
watch the Oh a watch something do
something but go to a bar when you know
the NFL is watching but know your target
but Mike how how is a player discipline
if there was sexual assault in college
how can the NFL you know what is the
jurisdiction there for the NFL to do
this to him as they did with terrelle
pryor for bartering to get tattoos it's
a it's a huge question and a huge issue
and the NFL has taken a really wide
latitude about this they look at it as
they wanted discipline guys like when
from what happened in college before
they got to the NFL and and it's
something that is I think it over steps
I don't think you should be punished
before we get into the league then but
that's that's their position and that's
a position that the Union has not really
fought on or at least is lost over but
it's not something I don't think the
NFL's do that's what they're doing and
it goes to this whole NFL now very much
into this sort of discipline discipline
phase they want to really get the
message of players that if you screw up
we're going to we're going to come after
you it's been a really uneven poorly
handled thing at times from Ray Rice to
some other issues Greg Hardy they really
are Greg Hardy they're really trying to
hammer it now and here we are we're
talking to Mike Freeman bleacher report
NFL reporter columnist it's been a
weirdly quiet offseason for the NFL
don't you get the feeling that the NFL
needs a good scandal that it is this bad
for the NFL that it's been a quiet
offseason is it that's because they need
they need the attention well yeah you
would have liked the Kaepernick story
slowed down I think if rg3 gets signed
by the Chargers then it will ramp up
just a little bit but we everybody sir
have said their piece with Kapernick you
know the Brady deflategate that that
funneled a lot of traffic to people you
haven't had much in the offseason I mean
lucky whitehead became a huge story but
you know other than that I don't know if
the NFL would be rooting for this I'm
sure the NFL reporters columnist would
like to have a little scandal here I'd
love one yeah what do you want to
Canadian Tenors I'm working I'm working
on one thing right now Mike but I'll
I'll let you know well I'll let you know
it has been it has been the quietest
offseason in a while I mean it really
has been it's been hasn't been a whole
lot of crazy so the Kaepernick stuff was
really as you said just like really it
boiled over and it's got a little choir
now because NFL teams are stupid and not
signing him but the one thing you one
point you made earlier is really
important and it's not necessarily about
the offseason any 511 or what were some
good stories about the future of the
league and high-end parents yeah and
this science and all of this data coming
out it's a really interesting time for
the league because of that point you
made what are parents going to react how
are they going to react to this and so
far it hasn't seemed to really massively
dent NFL's popularity but as more this
stuff comes out what will happen and I
think that's sort of we're just seeing
the evidence is going from it may cause
CTE to probably cause of CTE there's a
lot of layers left to unfold but it's
starting to get really really definitive
at least to me
so as it gets more definitive how will
parents react to it yeah and so far
they're not but it I think things are
going to change pretty quickly is Mike
framing the NFL economist bleacher
report also author of nine books
including snake the legendary life of
Ken Stabler good to talk to you again
Mike I'll see what I can do to help you
out with your next column okay then live
long and prosper
you thank you my the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience